¿Por qué una región con tantas
similitudes con Europa o Estados
Unidos es al mismo tiempo tan diferente?
¿Cómo es posible que la que fue durante
principios del siglo XX la región más
próspera del mundo se haya terminado
convirtiendo en una pesadilla de constantes
crisis, revoluciones y asaltos golpistas?
¿Qué explica que esta sea la
realidad social en América Latina?
Y la pregunta de las preguntas, ¿Por qué,
demonios, América Latina se ha quedado tan
atrás y sigue teniendo tantos problemas?
En este vídeo os contamos algunas de las
claves que explican porque un buen día en esta
región la prosperidad dio paso al declive.
Atentos.
[Pero antes,
dejadme haceros un apunte sobre Rusia, Putin, la
Guerra de Ucrania y las sanciones internacionales.
En un reciente vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik os
contamos en qué estado se encuentra la economía
rusa. Sin embargo, nos dejamos varias cosas en el
tintero que ahora podéis ver en el último vídeo
de Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que colaboramos.
Si quieres saber como están realmente la
economía rusa no te pierdas este vídeo.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
Y dicho esto, ahora si
arranquemos.
T1
(EL DESPEGUE DEL CÓNDOR)
Una historia común y una identidad cultural,
idiomática y social muy similar: pensadlo bien,
pocas regiones del mundo tienen tantos elementos
compartidos y tantas similitudes como
los países que integran América Latina.
Claro que, para entender, su realidad hoy,
tenemos que remontarnos hasta comienzos
del siglo XIX cuándo uno tras otro,
prácticamente todos los territorios
latinoamericanos alcanzaron su independencia.
Haití dio el pistoletazo de salida en 1804,
y poco tiempo después le siguieron el resto.
De esta forma si para comienzos del siglo
XIX América Latina seguía estando bajo
dominio de España, Portugal y Francia,
para mediados de siglo ya podíamos
encontrar un montón de nuevas repúblicas.
Nuevas repúblicas que nacieron tras un proceso
de independencia que también tuvo rasgos comunes:
el movimiento fue liderado por los propios
descendientes de los españoles, se buscaba la
independencia de todo el territorio y no solo
de unos pocos países y fue, fundamentalmente,
un proceso impulsado por las propias
élites económicas y políticas de la región.
Es decir, que por mucho que hoy algunos se
empeñen en decir lo contrario, la independencia
de América Latina no tuvo nada que ver con
una revolución de clases ni nada parecido.
Tan sólo tenemos que ver lo que,
por ejemplo, Karl Marx pensaba del líder de
la independencia americana, Simón Bolívar.
C1 (“(Bolívar) es el canalla más
cobarde, brutal y miserable” – Karl
Marx en una carta a Friedrich Engels, 1858. )
Sea como sea, el caso es que las nuevas repúblicas
tenían tantos recursos naturales que la mayoría
de ellas pronto empezaron a experimentar un fuerte
despegue económico. Rápidamente se convierten
en grandes potencias agrícolas y mineras.
(Las enormes plantaciones de café de Brasil,
los extensos campos de trigo y maíz de Uruguay
y Argentina, las minas de oro en México o
el cobre de Chile fueron un buen ejemplo. De
repente las exportaciones hicieron que las nuevas
repúblicas comenzaran a crecer con mucha fuerza.
Además, por aquel entonces el tamaño de estos
nuevos estados era muy pequeño mientras que
la facilidad para hacer negocios
e inmigrar era relativamente alta.
Como podéis ver esto hizo que entre 1900
y 1929 muchos de estos países crecieran
más que Europa o Estados Unidos. Por
entonces América Latina era una de las
regiones más prósperas de todo el mundo. El
crecimiento de Venezuela, por ejemplo, llegó
a triplicar al de Estados Unidos.)
Claro que no todo era luces. También
había muchas sombras.. Y sobre todo una
destacaba por encima de todas las demás.
Y es que, veréis, en estos países dónde
el sector agrícola tenía mucho peso, la
mayoría de las tierras, sobre todo en los países
relativamente más pobres, estaban en manos de
grandes terratenientes. Poco a poco esto alimentó
algunos movimientos campesinos de protesta como
los que estaban detrás de Emiliano Zapata en
México o José María de Santo Agostinho en Brasil.
Ya os hemos dicho que la independencia fue
liderada sobre todo por la oligarquía local,
familias oligárquicas que habían
hecho mucho dinero gracias en gran
medida a los privilegios que la corona
española les otorgó durante siglos.
Sea como sea, durante finales del siglo
XIX y comienzos del siglo XX gran parte
de América Latina disfrutó de
una enorme ola de prosperidad.
La máquina funcionaba a pleno rendimiento, los
barcos repletos de inmigrantes no paraban de
llegar desde el continente europeo y los productos
latinoamericanos estaban por todo el mundo.
Incluso en la bolsa de Londres era habitual
invertir en productos financieros de
países como la Argentina o Brasil. El sueño
americano también era cosa de América Latina.
Sin embargo, en 1929 todo empezó a cambiar.
De repente, el motor se empezó a gripar.
¿Por qué? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(EL CRACK DEL 29)
Los felices años 20, fueron años de una
enorme prosperidad. Fueron los años del
despegue definitivo de ciudades como
Buenos Aires, México DF o Sao Paulo.
Y también de otras tan conocidas como
Sidney, Toronto, Chicago o Nueva York.
Fue una época que vio nacer grandes rascacielos
y en la que se popularizó el uso del automóvil,
el teléfono o los electrodomésticos
en los países más desarrollados.
A ritmos de charleston y jazz, el mundo
parecía avanzar a toda velocidad. Y,
desde luego, América Latina no era una excepción.
Sin embargo, todo estalló en 1929
cuando el mundo vivió la crisis
económica más traumática que se
había conocido hasta la fecha,
(Martes 29 de
octubre, el pánico recorre las calles
de Nueva York tras la caída más precipitada de
la historia de las acciones en Wall Street. La
caída que empezó el pasado jueves, 24
de octubre, amenaza con arrastrar a la
economía mundial. La gente se apresura a
intentar blindar sus riquezas ante unas
perspectivas poco halagüeñas y el mundo está a
la expectativa de lo que suceda en Nueva York).
Exacto, queridos amigos, amigas de
VisualPolitik, en 1929 el mundo se
hundió en una fuerte crisis económica que terminó
derivando en la archiconocida Gran Depresión. El
comercio se contrajo, muchas empresas cerraron y
millones de trabajadores terminaron en el paro.
Este fue un punto de inflexión para
muchos países y, desgraciadamente también,
para la mayoría de las jóvenes
repúblicas de América Latina.
Digamos que en ese momento se interpretó
que el modelo exportador que había reinado
durante décadas, aunque había creado mucha
riqueza, también era extremadamente vulnerable.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Justo aquí
es cuando entra en escena un
economista que seguramente muchos no conoceréis,
pero que podríamos decir que fue algo así como
la versión latina de Keynes: Raúl Prebisch.
A partir de la Gran Depresión las ideas de
este economista argentino se expandieron y
consolidaron por toda la región. Más que un punto
de inflexión fue prácticamente un punto y aparte.
Ahora bien, la pregunta que
os estaréis haciendo es,
¿Y qué propuso exactamente este tipo? Pues,
básicamente un nuevo modelo de desarrollo.
Sentó las bases, ni más ni menos, que del modelo
conocido como “Industrialización por Sustitución
de Importaciones”, la política económica sobre la
que ha pivotado desde entonces prácticamente toda
América Latina. En VisualPolitik os hemos
hablado de ella en un montón de vídeos.
Pero, ¿En qué consistía exactamente? Pues… Fijaos.
La estrategia de Raúl Prebisch era muy clara:
América Latina tenía que industrializarse
y dejar atrás su dependencia del campo y
los recursos naturales. Y no solo eso, sobre todo
tenía que hacerlo mirando hacía dentro y no hacía
los mercados exteriores. La idea básicamente era
producir en casa todo aquello que se importaba.
Para lograrlo había que dar los siguientes pasos.
En primer lugar aumentar los aranceles y
endurecer la regulación para encarecer,
dificultar o, incluso, restringir las compras
en el extranjero. La idea era incentivar la
producción nacional, que con este incremento
del coste los consumidores optarán por la
producción nacional en lugar de comprarse, por
ejemplo, una clásica chaqueta Barbour británica.
Si se generaba esa demanda, las empresas
invertirían en incrementar su producción
y los países se industrializarían. Por
ejemplo, el nacimiento de empresas como
la Textil Iberoamericana o la Textil Valeria en
Argentina tuvieron mucho que ver con este proceso.
(Pero eso no es todo. Para acelerar el
proceso el Estado tenía que intervenir
directamente para favorecer a la emergente
industria nacional. Era algo que tenía que
hacer, por ejemplo, dando subvenciones y
créditos en condiciones muy preferentes.
A medida que estas empresas crecieran crearían
un montón de puestos de trabajo y nuevos ingresos
que contribuirían a impulsar la demanda… Y
con ello de nuevo todo el proceso. Además,
al no tener que importar tantos productos
saldrían muchos menos capitales de la región.
Esto permitiría crear según Prebisch
un enorme y próspero mercado local
que contribuiría no solo a industrializar
América Latina, sino también a mejorar más
rápido los estándares de vida. Digamos que
en lugar de crecer hacía fuera exportando,
lo que perseguía era crecer hacía dentro. Había,
por tanto, que sustituir las importaciones.)
Desde entonces, este modelo se convirtió en la
política pública favorita de la mayoría de los
gobiernos de la región. Por supuesto la Argentina
de Juan Domingo Perón fue su alumno más destacado.
Y, ojo, porque en general este nuevo
modelo empezó pisando fuerte. Sin embargo,
ya para finales de los 50 y de los 60 se
empezaron a ver los primeros problemas:
La sustitución de importaciones frenó
la entrada de inversión extranjera,
hizo que las empresas locales al tener mercados
cautivos fueran mucho menos competitivas y también
hizo que el cambio tecnológico fuera mucho más
lento. Y, además, lastró las cuentas públicas.
Los políticos cada vez prometían
más subsidios y planes de estímulo
para compensar tooodos esos problemas.
Y así poco a poco fue creciendo otro
de los grandes males de la región.
Atentos.
(LA DÉCADA PÉRDIDA)
Una pregunta: ¿Qué hace un estado, un gobierno
cuando no tiene lo suficiente
para conseguir dinero rápido?
Pues muy fácil… Tiene que pedirlo prestado.
Por supuesto, no toda la deuda es igual. No
es lo mismo endeudarse para pagar
salarios públicos que, por ejemplo,
para construir una red de autopistas
porque las carreteras ya no dan abasto.
El caso es que… el modelo de sustitución
de importaciones no había creado economías
más pujantes pero si estados mucho
más grandes y costes más elevados.
Y con estas en los 70 además se
produjo la tormenta perfecta.
Por un lado, la crisis del petróleo
redujo los ingresos públicos de muchos
de estos países. Por otro, los planes de
estímulo y desarrollo económico hicieron
que los gobiernos necesitarán mucho
dinero para sacar adelante sus planes.
¿El resultado? Creo que en este caso una imagen
vale más que mil palabrasLos gobiernos pidieron
enormes cantidades de dólares prestados
a tipos variables. Endeudarse en moneda
extranjera si se es un gran potencia
comercial puede ser llevadero, pero si
se ingresan pocos dólares porque el comercio
exterior es reducido, que es, precisamente,
lo que pasaba con el modelo de Sustitución de
Importaciones, entonces tienes un problema.
Y eso es exactamente lo que pasó.
(En 1980 la Reserva Federal de Paul Volcker
elevó con fuerza los tipos para enfrentarse
a la estanflación que atravesaba el país. Para
vencer a la inflación Volker empujó los tipos
de interés hasta el 19%... Lo que disparó
los costes de la deuda en América Latina.
El desastre estaba servido y la primera
economía en caer fue la mexicana que,
al poco tiempo, tuvo que pedir una
moratoria en el pago de su deuda.
Esto hizo que la confianza de los inversores en
la región terminará por desplomarse, lo que supuso
aún una menor entrada de dólares. Fue así como
dio comienzo la conocida cómo década pérdida.)
Y, ojo, porque aquí no hubo diferencias entre
izquierdas y derechas. Desde el México del
izquierdista PRI hasta la Colombia
del conservador Betancur Cuartas,
la crisis fue devastadora para todos.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué hicieron entonces todos
estos gobiernos? Pues… desgraciadamente como
ya no tenían dinero a muchos no se
les ocurrió otra cosa que darle a la
máquina de imprimir billetes… Ya sabéis,
para seguir estimulando la economía.
Esto hizo que de repente las hiperinflaciones se
convirtieran en un patrón habitual en la región.
Luego en los 90 los gobiernos intentaron girar
el timón… Pero los cimientos ya estaban rotos.
Una industria poco competitiva y obsoleta,
gobiernos enormes con muchos gastos y
pocos ingresos, bajas tasas de inversión
extranjera y políticos acostumbrados
a echarse en brazos del banco central.
Los ingredientes perfectos que nos ayudan a
entender porque esta región no consigue salir
del pozo. Con Raúl Prebisch, América Latina
rechazó el comercio y se distanció del modelo
capitalista imperante en Estados Unidos y Europa.
Por eso hoy nos puede sorprender que América
Latina sea al mismo tiempo
tan similar y tan distinta.
Y por supuesto también podríamos hablar de los
movimientos populistas, de los golpes de estado
o de las grandes deficiencias institucionales.
Pero sobre eso ya os hemos hablado en varios
vídeos tanto aquí en VisualPolitik como
en nuestro canal hermano VisualEconomik.
Un momento, ¿aún no lo conoces? Pues no te
olvides de echarle un vistazo. A VisualEconomik
y también a Si lo Hubiera Sabido. Ya sabéis que la
familia crece y lo hace gracias a todos vosotros.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Crees que las ideas de Raúl
Prebisch fueron claves para la
crisis perpetua que vive América Latina?
¿Qué otros factores tendrías en cuenta?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle a like y suscríbete a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.